four years ago William Holden Barbara
Stanwyck came up on the stage Spurs in
an award when they did mr. Holden
departed from the script to speak from
his heart he said that his career
derived from the lady standing next to
him but all he was came from her
generosity her support her biding belief
in him Barbara was completely surprised
by this she listened her public face
letting her private face show but just
for an instant
the actress in control that's the very
essence of Barbara Stanwyck eminence she
she in that hold she has in the audience
she's reality she's professional and
when she walks across the screen its
beauty and confidence she's always the
woman that she plays and yet always
herself
thank you thanks very much
I died thank the Board of Governors of
the Academy for giving me this special
award I many times to get it but I
didn't make it so this is indeed very
special to me oh you don't get them
alone there were writers directors
producers all their kindness to me
through the many years and the people
backstage the remarkable crews that we
have the privilege of working with the
electricians the property men stage ends
a camera they they're just marvelous and
my wonderful group they stunt men and
women who taught me so well I'm grateful
to them
and I thank them very very much a few
years ago I stood on this stage with
William Holden as a presenter I loved
him very much and I miss him he he
always wished that I would get an Oscar
and so tonight my golden boy you've got
your wish
you